the old water tower on the outskirts of
this shithill town has been derelict for
ages
it's amazing they haven't torn the damn
thing down yet
i reach up and get the next wrong which
groans in response to the unexpected
weight before snapping off entirely i
managed to catch myself at the last
second but my gopro isn't so lucky
it makes a soft plop in the snow below
there goes my perfect selfie
it was a close call though i'd take a
second to catch my breath before i steal
my nerves and continue my ascent
can turn back now
stick to the plan
you're gonna be remembered for this
i clamber onto the platform and i'm
greeted with an oversized grin a rival
school's idiotic mascot
its face is weathered and peeling
good thing he's about to get a brand new
paint job
now all i need to do is decide exactly
how many dicks i should add
time to get to work
there's one more over here
oh let's have one splooging all over it
pink
did i think i was gonna do with pink
paint
give him some missing teeth
he'll look just like these inbred
jackoffs
a little bit more
and
done
i stand back and admire my creation and
all its glory
in just a few hours people will wake up
to their beloved avatar being assaulted
by a group of floating penises as if it
were the star of a haunted [ __ ] now
all i need to do is snap some pics for
the guys to prove that yes i am that
badass
i whip out my cell and get to work
lamenting the fact that i can't post
these online
if only so i can hashtag dicasso
yeah it's as good a time as any for a
smoke
i spark one and look out over the woods
that surround the town
last night's snowfall blanketed the
landscape leaving a pristine coat of
white that went on for miles
i could see the lake off in the distance
from my vantage point i could clearly
see over the privacy fence that
encircles it
as the early morning fog began to
dissipate i could even see the water
surface and
what the
is that
i cut my hands around my eyes as if make
believe binoculars could somehow improve
my vision
and lean out over the railing
there's definitely something bobbing
about the surface
it looks like there's someone out there
that can't be right it is they closed
off the lake ages ago
something about an undertow
well it's not my problem some random
nobody gets themselves killed they're
closer than you'd think
as much as i want to turn away
i can't because you want to know the
truth i'm frozen to the spot
precariously hanging over the railing
there's something about them
something
familiar don't you remember the redhead
katie
we met in homeclass she was always so
patient and caring she still
took a trip with me and several of my
classmates over the summer to check out
the new space mountain
when we shared our first kiss during the
fireworks display on the third night i
made some dumb promises i knew i
couldn't keep
total blast to have around always wanted
me to tag along in his misadventures
we got caught sneaking in to see jaws
i managed to get away before the cops
showed up
he wasn't so lucky
never sold me out either
you always have my back don't let him
down
lived across the street from me our
entire lives he's been there the whole
time i could never ask for a better
friend
he began drifting apart once he started
getting pretty deep into his schoolwork
every once in a while he'd stop by
just to chill because he missed you
don't you miss him last time we talked
was
when he treated me to queen's show at
the paramount back in april
i fall backwards
reeling from a mix of vertigo from the
height
lightheadedness from the cigarette and a
sudden splitting migraine
i press my palms into my eyes trying to
get my head straight
i can't even focus on myself now though
there's people down there they need my
help
without even bothering to clean my
evidence i'll be back for it i drop the
ladder and begin climbing down
it's a quiet ride on my bike up to the
path that leads to the lake my crunchy
one for the last mile or so
the only sound other than me plodding
through the snow are the occasional
gusts of wind screaming through the
trees
danger
drowning hazard
harry is off limits
little signs like this were posted
everywhere
i disregard them and trek on i can't
abandon my friends now
it's funny
even though the sun is coming up it
seems to be getting colder
barbed wire
that's right how the hell am i supposed
to get over this
wait a minute
that bush
looks like there's a hole behind it
going right under the fence please on my
hands and knees i crawl through
i can see it now
it's everyone i know
every one of you
all my friends
my family
still others i don't recall in full you
shouldn't be here why
how can this be
i have to get you out of here i won't
let this go on
the freezing water is around my ankles
now with each step i can feel the ground
below getting further away up to my
thighs
and i'm already shivering
my heart begins to drop
something is wrong
[Music]
i'm slowly moving towards them
i can help
it doesn't have to be this way we can
all make it out of here
up to my chest
i can't shake the creeping dread from
being in such deep water
when i was a child an ill-advised
cannonball sent me pointing to the
bottom of my uncle's pool
i freaked i couldn't move
i flailed about in panic trying
desperately to gain vertical ground to
no avail
i thought i was gonna die
someone got down in time to fish me out
but ever since then i've had a horrible
phobia of water
in fact i've never actually learned how
to swim
up to my neck
it's too late now
i can't find the bottom
i can't get footing
i'm choking on the water and i'm
starting to flail again
[Music]
[Music]
they can't do that
you you can't leave me here
don't
forget me
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
jebby
pure osmium
scio dio demnatus
[Music]
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbich
kawaii fire keeper
longinus
death aqua
king madding
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogen
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you